un [ __ ] comienza a caminar en el
vértice de un triángulo equilátero en
cada movimiento elije aleatoriamente uno
de los dos vértices donde no se
encuentra parado y se arrastra a lo
largo del lado del triángulo ha dicho
vértice dado que la probabilidad de que
el [ __ ] se mueva a su vértice inicial
en el décimo movimiento es m / n donde m
y n son enteros positivos y primos
relativos calcula m + n muy bien
entonces esencialmente cuando nos dicen
que me llene son primos relativos nos
están diciendo que no hay factores en
común entre m y n y si no hay factores
en común quiere decir que está esta
fracción está simplificada lo más que se
puede ya estar lo más simplificada
posible muy bien entonces ahora lo que
lo que vamos a hacer es un dibujo para
visualizar bien qué está pasando con
este [ __ ] curioso porque dice que
tenemos un triángulo
un triángulo equilátero y que este tiene
tres vértices digamos abc
suponemos que hay un [ __ ] que se mueve
de esta forma como indica digamos que
empieza en el vértice a muy bien tenemos
aquí nuestro [ __ ] que se mueve a lo
largo de los lados de este triángulo
para ir llegando a los otros vértices
entonces la elección es al azar entonces
estando en nada tiene probabilidad un
medio de moverse ave y probabilidad un
medio de moverse hace nos dicen la
información de que me entrene es la
probabilidad de que haya regresado al
vértice a después de 10 movimientos así
que vamos viendo qué va pasando en cada
movimiento digamos
con el vértice a el vértice b y el
vértice c
qué pasa con el primer movimiento bueno
cuál es la probabilidad de que al
moverse una vez quede nada bueno pues
empezó en nada así que no puede volver a
llegar a porque siempre se tiene que
mover así que la probabilidad de llegar
a es cero
sin embargo cuál es la probabilidad de
llegar a ver dado que estén a la
probabilidad de llegar a veces un medio
porque lo elige al azar lo elige a la
aleatoriamente lo mismo pasa para ser
verdad como esta en a pues puedes saltar
hace con probabilidad un medio vamos a
ver qué pasa en el segundo movimiento
muy bien segundo movimiento
cuando como puede llegar al vértice a al
vértice a perdón en el segundo
movimiento puede ser que esté en b y
después elija llegará pero cuál es la
probabilidad de que estén b en el paso
anterior pues es un medio así que
tenemos un medio de que esté en b por un
medio de que elija llegar a pero no sólo
eso también podemos pensar que estaba en
seco y eso es y eso ocurre con
probabilidad en medio y dado que estén
se elija llegar a que eso tiene
probabilidad de un medio entonces
tenemos un medio por un medio es un
cuarto más un medio por un medio que es
otro cuarto son dos cuartos y esos son
eso es exactamente un medio ahora bien
cuál es la probabilidad de que en el
segundo movimiento esté en b bueno
pensemos que estaba en a entonces en el
primero puede llegar a veo hace entonces
realmente para que en el siguiente
movimiento llegue a be sólo puede ser
que parta desde ese porque si en él si
en el primer movimiento llegaba ave pues
no se puede quedar ahí mismo se tiene
que mover así que sólo puede pasar que
en el movimiento anterior esté en cee y
eso ocurre con probabilidad un medio y
estando en se decide a pasarse al
vértice be que ocurre con probabilidad
en medio y esto es un cuarto muy bien
entonces lo mismo pasa para hacer verdad
como no podía estar en el paso anterior
ence entonces necesariamente viene del
vértice b que eso ocurre con
probabilidad de un medio y elegir saltar
al vértice c
ocurre con probabilidad de un medio y
que es un cuarto entonces si nos fijamos
primero en una una forma de ver que más
o menos estamos haciendo las cosas bien
es ver que la suma de los de las
probabilidades es siempre una verdad por
ejemplo aquí es cero más un medio más un
medio es uno un medio más un cuarto más
un cuarto también es uno muy bien pero
podemos pasar a un caso más general
digamos digamos que estamos en el paso n
muy bien digamos que estamos en el paso
n y queremos ver no podemos decir
digamos que la probabilidad de que
estemos en el paso en el vértice a es
pda que la probabilidad de estar en el
vértice pspv y la probabilidad de estar
en el vértice se desperece como
calculamos la probabilidad de que esté
en el vértice a
en el paso n 1 pues esencialmente nos
dice bueno pues la probabilidad de que
esté en b verdad y que decida saltar
eso ocurre con probabilidad de un medio
pero también puede pasar que estén se y
elija con probabilidad un medio saltar y
lo mismo pasa para b hay que ver la
probabilidad de que estén ahí y que
decida saltar ave más la probabilidad de
que estén se decide a saltar ave y
finalmente para la probabilidad de ese
es la probabilidad de que esté en a y
decía saltar hace más la probabilidad de
que estén ve y decide saltar hace
entonces si nos damos cuenta en todos
estos es el promedio verdad es el
promedio de las probabilidades de los
otros vértices en el paso anterior y sí
porque tenemos pdv por un medio más
perece por un medio esto es lo mismo que
prevé más pdc todo eso dividido entre
dos y es un promedio y eso pasa para
estas tres cantidades entonces con esto
dicho ya va a ser mucho más sencillo
calcular los siguientes los siguientes
pasos vamos a seguir nuestra fila acá
nuestras filas digamos estos a b
vamos a ver qué pasa con el tercer
movimiento bueno en el tercer movimiento
tenemos que promediar para el vértice a
lo que pasó en el segundo movimiento
para dice que es un cuarto más un cuarto
entre dos que es un cuarto verdad
un cuarto y luego para ver tenemos que
promediar el de a y el de c que es un
medio más un cuarto
estos son digamos tres cuartos verdad
son dos cuartos más un cuarto son tres
cuartos o lo que es lo mismo como no
podemos dividirlo bien entre dos podemos
pensar que son seis cuartos perdón seis
octavos y al dividirlo entre dos son 33
octavos creo que lo dije bien otra vez
tenemos un medio más un cuarto son tres
cuartos que es lo mismo que seis octavos
si lo promediamos es decir dividimos
entre dos tenemos tres octavos también
puedes pensar lo que la suma es perdón
en si la suma de son tres cuartos y al
dividirlo entre dos es como multiplicar
por dos en el denominador que se dan
tres octavos y realmente la probabilidad
ahora en el vértice c es también tres
octavos es también tres octavos porque
se van
son los mismos verdad la probabilidad de
b y la probabilidad de c de hecho ya
puedes aquí darte cuenta de algún patrón
verdad
al menos la probabilidad de be y la
probabilidad de se van a tener que ser
igualitos
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa en el paso
4 el promedio de bs para que nos vea es
tres octavos tres octavos de hecho
también aquí puedes ver otro patrón
siempre nos va a dar la probabilidad de
a el promedio de b y c en el paso
anterior muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa con beige en este en este momento
tenemos que sumar
tenemos que sumar un cuarto más tres
octavos un cuarto más tres octavos son
dos octavos más cinco octavos y al
dividir entre dos son cinco
dieciseisavos cinco dieciseisavos y lo
mismo para hacer cinco dieciseisavos
vamos a ver qué pasa en el quinto
movimiento digamos aquí la probabilidad
de a es simplemente lo que hay en
beijing sé que son
dieciseisavos en vez vamos a ver
tenemos que sumar tres octavos más cinco
dieciseisavos tres octavos son seis
dieciseisavos y cinco dieciseisavos son
veintiuno dieciseisavos y entre dos son
si se ven las cuentas creo que no verdad
son seis y cinco son once 91 muy bien
tenemos once dieciseisavos y al
dividirlo entre dos son once 32avos
tengo que cuidar mucho mis mis
operaciones porque no sé por qué mi
cabeza está pensando en eso lo mismo
pasa para hace muy bien y entonces
quizás también ya sigues viendo este
tipo de patrones vamos a ver un último
caso digamos para el caso de seis de
seis muy bien en caso de seis se repiten
estos que es 11 32 y ahora vamos a hacer
el promedio de cinco dieciseisavos y 11
32 a 25 dieciseisavos son diez diez
32avos
y 11 tenemos 21 32avos y dividido entre
2 tenemos 21 entre 64 y este se repite
verdad entonces vamos a ver si podemos
hacer algo en el séptimo paso se repiten
son 21 entre 64 y vamos a ver qué tipo
de patrón podemos encontrar por ejemplo
para vamos a adelantarlo directamente
los pasos 8 9 y 10
aunque podemos ver podemos ver que el
denominador realmente sólo nos interesa
saber la probabilidad de estar en verdad
entonces
si nos damos cuenta en el denominador
son potencias de 2 verdad aquí es 2 4 8
16 32 64 y esencialmente aquí es 2 a la
12 a la 22 a la 32 a la 42 a las 5
entonces estamos elevando a la potencia
anterior verdad es decir aquí estamos 2
elevando a las 5 que es el paso anterior
verdad entonces por ejemplo en el paso 8
tendríamos 2 elevado a las 7 que es 2
por 64 que son 128 acá serían 256 y aquí
serían 512 verdad entonces ahora al
menos ya tenemos el denominador ya
sabemos quién es nuestra n ahora sólo
nos falta saber quién es el numerador
así que piensa por ejemplo en este de
aquí si nos damos cuenta esto lo podemos
ver como 3
verdad 32 eso nos da 5 y 11 lo podemos
ver como 5 más 6 que es el doble de este
21 lo podemos ver como 11 más el doble
de 5 que es 10 así que el numerador
parece ser que nuestro patrón va a ser
el numerador anterior y el doble del
numerador del anterior del anterior es
decir de hace dos pasos muy bien
entonces en este caso el doble de 11
serían 22 más 21 serían 43 ahora aquí
tendríamos el doble de 21 serían 42 43
serían 85 y finalmente el doble de 43
son 86 85
171 muy bien entonces ya tenemos nuestra
respuesta el numerador es 171 y 512 es
el denominador pero no nos preguntan eso
nos preguntan cuál es la suma de estos
dos así que tenemos que calcular 512 más
171 y esto nos da 2 y 1 son 37 y 1 son
85 y 1 son 6 así que la respuesta es 600
683 ok pero bueno realmente no sé
ustedes pero yo me siento un poquito
incómodo porque no hemos visto realmente
si la fórmula funciona así que solo solo
por mera diversión vas a usar a
demostrar la fórmula de que si es cierto
muy bien tenemos la probabilidad de a la
probabilidad de b y la probabilidad de c
digamos en el paso n en el paso n es
algo vimos que la probabilidad de a es
un número
2 a la n muy bien 2 a la sala n
creo que sn - uno muy bien dos a la n 1
ok y en vez tendremos b sobre 2 a la n 1
verdad fíjense muy bien en como lo
hicimos acá como lo hicimos acá por
ejemplo aquí en el 4 tenemos algo entre
2 al cubo y aquí sería entonces no es la
n 1 es a la n
muy bien ahí lo tenemos verdad porque
aquí si es 2 a la 4 que son 16 y como en
belén se son iguales entonces tendremos
b entre 2 alain que pasa en el paso
número n 1 entonces el promedio de a
sera
justamente se repetían el de verdad que
es ve entre dos a la n iv en este
tendremos que sumar el de a y el de cee
que es a entre dos a la n menos uno más
de entre dos a la n iv esto dividirlo
entre dos cuanto vale esto bueno esto
sería aquí podríamos multiplicar por dos
y si multiplicamos por dos abajo también
y nos queda dos a la n 2 a la n iv esto
que es ya tenemos mismo denominador así
que sólo nos queda 2
además b entre 2 por 2 a la n que es 2 a
la n 1 muy bien pero en el paso n 2 en
el paso n más 2 se repite lo que ya
teníamos embellece que es 2a más b sobre
2 a la n 1 entonces esto verifica
nuestra fórmula porque el denominador es
la potencia de 2 elevado a un paso
anterior
que sn uno es un paso anterior de n 2 y
nos dice que el numerador se calcula de
la siguiente forma el doble de hace dos
pasos más el numerador del paso anterior
así que esto verifica nuestra fórmula
que empezamos a deducir que vimos
anteriormente y ya podemos quedarnos con
un muy muy buen sabor de boca de nuestra
respuesta que además de todo y está
demostrada